mario paul ce matin
le cessez-le-feu décrété par les russes
n'a pas tenu impossible de savoir qui a
tiré en premier
un couloir humanitaire devait arriver
ici mais personne ne sort de l'usiné of
talent
cette usine pilonnaient depuis des jours
et des jours par les russes est le
dernier bastion ukrainiens de mariupol
des civils ils sont réfugiés
juste à côté ce quartier complètement
dévastée
au milieu des ruines marine a fait sa
tournée tous les jours elle s'est
improvisée infirmières j'ai des
médicaments un appareil pour la tension
y'a pas le médecin ici il n'y a personne
aussi cette femme à 80 non elle a été
blessée par des éclats d'obus voilà elle
a un trou là
mon bras me fait souffrir j'ai du mal à
le lever ça me fait mal
ces blessures ont du mal à cicatriser
comme tout le monde ici elle survit dans
une cave sans eau ni électricité
à la cousine à veut nous montrer ce
qu'il reste de son appartement
il n'y a plus de balcon si je montais au
troisième étage je tomberai au deuxième
c'est là c'est le deuxième balcon en
partant du bas
pour tenir elle s'accroche aux petits
gestes du quotidien
les obus russe qui vise à obstacles
passe juste au dessus de sa tête
[Musique]
les bombardements les avions
la moitié de la route est ouverte
l'autre moitié elle est fermée à cause
des combats et si on est comme sur la
ligne de front et puis elle cuisine pour
son voisin
sa femme est morte le 9 avril dans un
bombardement au bout de 5 jours il s'est
résolu à l'enterrer lui même avec
quelques voisins dans la cour
je ne sais pas comment l'éclat lui est
rentré dans la tête on était serrés côte
à côte elle a été touchée et pas moi et
c'est fini je les enterrer j'ai fait une
inscription
tout est comme brûlé à l'intérieur de
moi je ne ressens plus rien quels
sentiments je pourrais encore avoir
après avoir vécu ça sous les yeux
sur la tombe il a mis quelques
confiseries pour pâques
juste à côté
trois corps gisent là depuis plusieurs
semaines à peine recouvert d'une
couverture
personne ne sait de qui il s'agit
accompagné par un soldat séparatiste pro
russe nous nous rapprochons des
obstacles ici on sent même longue de
choc des explosions
ce soldat arrive du front il nous
raconte qu'il y a aussi des combats
intenses au sol mais que l'ordre de
lancer l'assaut n'a pas été donnée il
arrive à la fin de leurs munitions de
leurs armes ils sont fatigués pour le 9
mai on doit essayer de prendre tout ça
et je pense qu'on va y arriver ce serait
vraiment bien
cette bataille d'un hôpital qui fait
rage juste là elle est très symbolique
pour vladimir poutine prendre ce dernier
bastion ukrainiens de mariupol ce serait
comme une victoire a affiché pour le 9
mai qui est en russie une grande fête
patriotique